there's been a
shooting in the subway in new york city
yeah okay yeah
we were all thinking it guys
okay
al we need to take this
hal
you're laughing
go to you go to you zoom
why are you laughing
[Laughter]
so
so so listen
listen we should be we should be serious
about this yeah this is serious there
was a shooting so far no one has passed
away yeah as according as to this google
search as well right now which is good
also no life-threatening injuries so no
[Music]
basically this guy
he's uh he's from philadelphia
drives up here confirmed from philly
yeah he rented a u-haul in philadelphia
oh he went to the u-haul in philadelphia
yeah um i'm hoping mark you have some
conspiracy theories about this
my understanding is the reason that they
found out that it was him is because he
left his credit card in the tracks
is that true pretty convenient that's
just what keith robinson told me last
night
they have images of him that someone
took on their cell phone
yeah stupid
i like that conspiracy better though
what
because the video from the subway
station non-operational obviously
because it's a [ __ ] new york city
subway but they said this could be
watching them
talking about a subway like that ain't
nobody died
we got the most lit subway ever yeah no
you just had the worst gunman
that wasn't us the biggest loser ever
yeah over 26 on bullets that's my point
how did you shot 26 bullets yeah
yeah you had no life-threatening
injuries because he did the smoke first
black people leave the mass shootings to
the whites yeah that's
i was surprised as a black guy because
he had so many like uh trinkets and [ __ ]
you know what i mean like he had like
the smoke the white things and like yeah
yeah
it's kind of white resourcefulness
that's us take a box cutter whole plain
there's no stereotypes for black
terrorists yet you had the dc sniper
that was actually i think it's kind of
cool i think but he was good he was a
sniper [ __ ] sniper that's kind of
fire yeah that's why i'm like when stuff
was left behind it didn't go all [ __ ]
uh extra bullets were left in the scene
i was like
can't be us
oh you thought it wasn't black
it's a very swagless shooting yeah yeah
also at whites we wouldn't shoot up a
subway
maybe or maybe the rest what you mean it
might be subway though
the subway come on come on but what's it
used to be subway at school i don't
understand it's above where above we're
above we're both
i'm gonna go down and shoot people you
know what i mean
we
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
yeah
is like that shot countrywide is country
not respected i mean that's amazing yo
that's gonna answer that one that's some
like rich white person mentality you got
oh
alex is a rich white dude yeah yeah
that's white middle-class white
look down on country yeah
he divided all the whites amongst the
world who did no no that's different
that's different you grew up rich we
don't know this that's what i'm saying
hey hey you're saying you're the same
white as my cmt
salsa
okay they thought salsa they made your
chili ring
they did
no but they taught salsa does that make
a person rich
apparently yeah a little bit
that just sounds way better when you say
it like that
yes they were very industrious and
developed a great business
teaching some salsa some swing yeah
absolutely right that's why he would
divide the white people why would i
divide the white people my parents are
about bringing together people but
you're rich white so you look at poor
whites as not white how many people were
shot
ten people yeah ten people were shot
how many people were shot going into the
subway here's the thing a lot of people
don't realize some people might have
been shot before they got on the subway
yeah that's true and they're going to
the hospital
how many people did that guy even shoot
the black guy
why did it say he's raising
terrorism we like to say exactly what
that white male black male yeah muslim
true that's true
right what hal come on you got it black
shooters are like black streamers all
right they have it harder bro yeah
does it bother you that he wasn't that
good at it like he knows that makes me
happy but he was like a little lazy
about it you probably got on the train a
little late you know what i mean like
one time where stereotypes are beautiful
yeah they're like why why why nobody
died
say what no one died because he sucks
the bomb didn't go off because he sucks
oh there was an actual bomb yeah
allegedly his dumbass you know he's not
from new york because he didn't know how
long it was going to take to get to the
next stop
he pulled that [ __ ] smoke bomb he's
just sitting there coughing with
everybody else then he shot [ __ ]
idiot he had a gas mask dummy no
no he decided have to stop the spread
that's what it was it was cova oh it was
cold yeah that's what he did yeah that's
what he said he was responsible yeah i
think big masks was behind this they
wanted everybody massed up and they said
look how important this is if there's
terrorism you can breathe
i always honestly my conspiracy brain
was going the other way i was like is
this how they get us to take down their
masks we don't know where he is
everybody's messed up it's so easy to
commit he was trying a mask but he was
but if you see someone mass and
everybody isn't then boom you know you
yeah
yeah what do you think his [ __ ]
come on guys you're crazy dude what do
you think it looks like dark knight bro
do you think it's dark
horizon
oh man
so al yeah did you get a call from your
uncle after he did it or like
what what what was the whole deal you
know i don't know my uncles
yeah that's [ __ ] up nah that was
really disappointed he was black i was
most i was mostly hungry because i had
to bike home
i was in manhattan had to bike back to
brooklyn because i was like i don't want
to why risk it yeah the real that's the
real tragedy of this no he's right you
stayed off the subway yeah
because i'm literally riding the bike in
between traffic there's like semi trucks
like crisscrossing and i was like this
is way more dangerous than you can train
can i tell you something i've heard a
lot of people i've heard a lot of people
go like i'm going to take the subway
because what are the chances it's going
to happen again i bet some people
thought about that on 9 11.
come on
they hit the first one and then the
people in the second one like ain't no
way oh see ain't no way another plane
gonna hit us what's the chances
like we're going to dc they're not doing
two seasons right yeah you know what i'm
saying so it was what ow what i'm saying
is you you paid attention to history and
you made why are you laughing at [ __ ]
9 11 yeah
you're crazy you're
you're crazy because you're laughing at
that and i'm trying to take something
serious yeah be sure i was pretty
serious you're crazy
i'm trying to be serious right now mark
could have been on the second [ __ ]
subway son yes
yeah
what do you think how would you have how
would you have gotten out of the
situation
me yeah would you take that allen key of
a dick of yours and just throw it right
yeah yeah did you know how did you do
that
little [ __ ] ikea wrench you got and
then and you just put it right there and
so just twist my hips once and all of a
sudden it's locked up yeah that's
actually why the trigger jammed oh
there you go hey let's go with me were
you actually the savior yeah dog that's
who i am that's what i do you're a
[ __ ] g dude hey i'm a hero you are a
hero dude yeah you're welcome hey al
you're welcome what what subway didn't
happen
what training happened on you know what
it to happen on the l nope the n
oh wow
what the
[Music]
[Music]
hey
that [ __ ] gave me flashbacks
back in texas
that's just crazy that's the most
country i've ever seen miles all right
guys we'll take a break for a second
because today's video is sponsored by
surfshark surfshark is a modern vpn
designed with the user in mind their
utilities are powered by robust security
mechanisms but designed to be simple and
intuitive to use enjoy all the freedoms
of an open internet safely and
anonymously with no device limits okay
there are strictly no logs means that
you do not have your data kept by them
your data is yours okay you can unlock
the 15 largest netflix uh
country libraries if you don't know this
already each country has different
movies and tv shows on netflix and this
will allow you to unlock all 15 of the
largest ones u.s japan all you have to
do is be able to connect the server and
then log in okay you can reach your
favorite sites and services even in
countries that ban them as surf shark
bypasses censorship and geo-blocking to
give you access to facebook in china or
tick-tock in the usa 30-day money-back
guarantee given users plenty of time to
try out surf shark risk free think about
that you have 30 days to see how awesome
it is and after you realize how awesome
it is there's no question you're going
to ask for your money back but you could
actually get it back so
right now you can get 83 off a two-year
plan with three extra months for free 83
off think about that all you got to do
is go to
surfshark.deals
schultz that's
s-c-h-u-l-z use the code schultz
s-c-h-u-l-z to get 83 off a two-year
plan and three extra months for free
protect yourself online today remember
that is https
colon forward slash forward slash
surfshark.com
dot deals slash schultz and use the code
schultz to get 83 off a two-year plan
and three extra months for free protect
yourself online
yeah jesus miles i mean you're a [ __ ]
crazy guy why did you think it was the l
say again why do you think it was the l
coming from brooklyn come from brooklyn
uh yeah and also like he kind of took an
l on it that is true that's true why did
he do a train in brooklyn does anyone
know
is there a reason why he would do that
why he would do the train in brooklyn
like why is he not if like going to
manhattan why is he picking like a
random stop
in like kind of deep brooklyn
this guy aimed very low as is mark's
point
it seems weird to me real underrated one
thing was that it was going into
chinatown was what people were
theorizing
that's
that's what some people are saying i
don't know yo dude like
the way that you try to paint blacks
against asians
i'm just saying that's what people are
saying on twitter all right stop agent
hate people aren't saying that
that's what marcus i tweeted it i did
tweet it but
some other people also retweeted it
[Laughter]
these guys are nuts
i'm just trying to stop asian hate huh
dude that's what you think is he was
planning that tack for chinatown why
give up so early
yeah i don't really know i don't
understand that's that [ __ ] slow some
ways he was like i'm done waiting
i'm done bro
you know what's interesting about this
that he left his credit card in the
tracks
but that is weird don't you think that's
a little conspiratorial that his credit
card was on the tracks
yeah
and how'd they find his u-haul before
they found him
his credit card was on the tracks dude
and he deleted his email server you you
didn't hear this
he dropped his laptop off at a laptop uh
and there's all this information on it
you didn't you didn't see this at all
it's scary the stuff he believes so
because he came in today he's like he's
such a bummer that those three people
died in the shooting and i googled it i
was like i don't think anyone's died so
far this [ __ ] woman that lives with
me forever
told me
this [ __ ] lady i wasn't gonna say
this this lady that lives with me from
my life
said to me this morning it's so tragic
that two people died you know how many
people you went around saying that
you got to call them
i was talking about this last night i
was making jokes about it yeah thinking
that people survived
yeah
all of them
they did they did well why weren't
bonnie's a woman in my home forever she
just wanted to not take the train she
just wanted to be like yo [ __ ] dad take
it she's been trying to convince me that
new york is dangerous and i'm like man
you just don't want to walk the dog at
night y'all just be like
and and but now she might be right then
she's super right you think she's super
right new york is kind of dangerous bro
it's not it's just as dangerous as any
other city stop it what the [ __ ] are you
talking about any other major city is
just as dangerous we were in [ __ ]
miami and there was matching going on it
was a guy who got shot up at the mall
what happened when did that happen
when we were in miami's fifth
oh really we weren't even in miami
august no no no no no no but he's what
happened there i love him he's right
he's right it checks out another day
yeah december 12th december 12th we
weren't even
oh it's gonna be in the future
crime data
responsible for 50 of them
this is how it starts out and you're
co-signing it i'm waiting i'm waiting to
see what the fact is yeah yeah yeah say
say what you want to say
looks like miami is pretty high see uh
it's higher than new york
this is a safer city
that's the biggest
load of [ __ ]
oh now you don't believe david.com
[Laughter]
oh
you almost got me back but i'm still
looking at you
you gotta look at them sideways yeah or
how girls look at akash is sandy hook
okay you can't look at that [ __ ]
straight on my head is the g
short not reliable
with the fatty crook you don't want to
ride this train [ __ ] where's your bend
in your dick it's right at the tip oh
that's like yeah it's like an uppercase
l oh that's so dope dude
moan more i'm gonna do it more money oh
oh i love [ __ ] wow
[Music]
dude which part gets hard first
does it go base to the tail it goes it
goes this way
no i know yeah yeah but i'm saying like
as it gets hard is it all one time or
just the base and that just hangs like
the end of a sock and then that starts
to fill yeah it softens it blows it like
a yeah you tell us yeah
and then it just takes that left yeah
yeah
dude that's so [ __ ] awesome so more
violent crime in my image
so no one cares about your fake
statistics yeah get out of here
these are real
white people love facts dude worries
about being subject to physical attack
because your skin color ethnic origin
generally i don't care about worries fam
what is a worry yeah worry just racism
what do you mean the more racist you are
the more worried you are you're around
black
people that's true you like racist stats
that's why you're emmett too
i don't think you got i think wasn't
that the woman's name
emma you're on my team hey you're emma
who's this that's the woman the woman
that accused emmett till was emmett yeah
that's true in case you don't know yeah
i didn't know that they were related
yeah
that's why they didn't want
intermarriage back in the year yes bro
look how long come on bro stop making
jokes geez
son can we can we actually start the
podcast please because y'all are crazy
and i got mad scissors
don't make jokes by emmett tilbury he
was innocent yeah he was and he was
innocent they didn't find his credit
card anywhere
[Laughter]
that lady though the lady to be in my
space constantly
son
this woman that brings me coffee in the
morning bro yo she was saying some wild
[ __ ] about it i just always got the best
misinformation bro say what wives of the
best misinformation oh yeah talk about i
didn't come
[Music]
stupid stupid
stupid stupid what
hey
[Laughter]
the shooter who dropped the credit card
as he fled the scene was still in the
loose tuesday night you see that the
shooter who dropped the credit card
y'all are not seeing that everybody's
dropped your credit card this is mkl
everyone's dropped to chris
the comedian that dropped a credit card
have you ever dropped a credit card this
is russia what do you think this is mkl
this is russia
yes this if we're really gonna be
conspiratorial yeah that's good the
[ __ ] got a whole mask on got all
the trinkets and he just throws his
credit card onto the tracks oh that's
convenient doesn't that seem like
something that the cia or fbi would do
before and then the light just turned
off maybe like i'm wrong maybe he was
trying to frame someone else
exactly
this is a patsy scheme
okay
this is this is like jfk it's a
government scheme it's a government
patch this is like jfk dude this is
[ __ ] jfk i believe it
no way this was black dude i'm on board
thank you bro
thank you bro i'm on board of course the
guy has a full mask on how the [ __ ]
anybody gonna say what he looks like
that's racist in and of itself you just
assume he's a black guy yeah that's true
like i'm sorry you can't just assume
it's a black guy son preach bruh like
you don't even know if he's black and
then what ethnicity is he say again what
it's gotta be white if it's a conspiracy
it was on the way to chinatown
and through a car smoke and a car like a
one star
wow smoke bomb
smoke bomb i'm just saying
i'm just saying look at the report he
was selling baby turtles too
look at the report he had six baby
turtles for sale
on the subway look at the report
there was baby turtles
for for sale apparently he was five five
five five uh hello no boy there you go
hello
wow hello i mean i don't want to start
asian hate again but there's a lot of
things leaning in that direction
we would have killed more than no people
for sure
could be indian yeah but if we wanted to
yeah we got that i think they would have
did a better job wait no [ __ ]
question no he they loved trains yeah
but they would have yeah
we killed more people just writing our
own trends just writing
do you think we wanted to kill people
it'd be hard come on like they would
have been afraid to disappoint their
parents and [ __ ] like that
that's true that's true yeah
i mean nobody has said jews yet i just
want to point that out
yeah because we're on microphones oh oh
yes
sorry about that sorry about that
and you do what put it above the door
is that true mark that is true mark yeah
mark are you are you playing one of your
games before no this is true this is a
true biblical fact dude mark mark is
probably what do they take yeah what do
you mean who's do this it's a lamb
there's a lamb a virgin lamb
he said can you please fascinate me
no this is true they take the blood of a
lamb this guy's over there is a real
piece of work then the angel of death
will cross over your home
to indicate who the jews were bro
i remember seeing this on a disney movie
i think what up people you just watched
a clip from our weekly patreon episode
you can support the flagrancy you can
support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant two all right peace